[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un prêtre orthodoxe visée à deux
reprises par un individu armé devant son
église à lyon son pronostic vital est
engagé le tireur est toujours en fuite
on ne connaît pas encore ses motivations
la police judiciaire de lyon est saisi
aucune piste n'était
alors que des manifestations hostiles à
la france poursuit dans le monde arabo
musulman dans un entretien accordé à la
principale chaîne d'information du qatar
emmanuel macron dit comprendre que les
caricatures puisse choquer mais dénonce
la violence le qatar fait partie des
pays qui ont appelé au boycott des
produits français
et puis la côte d'ivoire a voté
aujourd'hui pour élire un nouveau
président l'opposition elle a incité les
électeurs à la désobéissance civile le
président lui a appris au calme un
scrutin sous forte tension à cause de
cette troisième candidature contestée
d'alassane ouattara matériel électoral
brûlé bureaux fermés ou bloqué de
nombreux incidents ont été signalés à
travers le pays
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france est la
une de l'actualité ce samedi un prêtre
de 52 ans visé par un individu ce samedi
à lyon ils étaient en train de fermer
son église orthodoxe lorsqu'il a été
ciblé par un homme armé qui a tiré à
deux reprises sur ce prêtre de
nationalité grecque
blessé grièvement à l'abdomen son
pronostic vital est engagé il a été
médicalisé aussitôt sur place
le tireur lui est toujours en fuite ce
soir
les faits se sont déroulés rue saint
lazare dans le 7e arrondissement de la
ville
un périmètre de sécurité a aussitôt été
installé autour des lieux de l'agression
et la police judiciaire de lyon a été
saisie on va faire le point tout de
suite avec notre correspondant sur place
à lyon luis carballo
bonsoir à louise vous suivez évidemment
le déroulement de ces opérations
actuellement à lyon le suspect est
toujours en fuite
avez vous d'autres informations bonsoir
et bakel n'était pas encore un truc
c'est que je finissais pas au contraire
c'est marrant parce qu est il ya assisté
qui a été interpellé dans ces rues qui
n'est pas très loin
les investissements se sont élevés à 23
km 1
dans les 3e arrondissement c3 et une
information comme quoi et tu cliques
enfin suspect quelqu'un annonce et c est
a été interpellé par la par la police et
il ya peu près trois cent trente ou
quarante minutes dans l'anglais et entre
l'avenue félix faure et la rue baraban
nous on est là on se place on sera
déplacée et mais on voit aucune
déploiement de police à fès et la
formation de la vessie qu'ils avaient
été interpellés dans cent dans un
restaurant dans un kebab et mais quand
je vous lis à ce moment il n'y a pas
d'opération policiers du si alma en tout
cas ça je peux vous confirmer il ya
quelqu'un qui était interpellé
je sais pas encore si c'est le teaser au
nom qui ne porterait pas d'armes sur lui
ainsi ce conte
disait également pour l'instant aucune
piste n'est écartée c'est ce qu'a dit
également le maire de lyon quel est
qu'elle est comment s'est déroulée cette
agression un racontez-nous ce qui s'est
passé aux alentours de 16 heures cet
après midi à lyon
oui c'était un projet super combiné
glissé organes y est les fesses un
samedi sans quelqu'un qui était nouveau
dans la paroisse dans l'église en tout
cas et il venait à peine d'arriver en
france 50 et 100 en plus des frais les
familles les pères de famille et donc
icône il était en train d'être fermés
l'église sur les investisseurs un
individu se rapproche de lui la thur
herbe au portant et à deux reprises il
ya eu en fait des concessions sur les
armes et aurait pu très utilisée pour
profitation revue
enfin c'est ce qu'on attendait ce
qu'elles étaient décédées par le mais il
ya aussi une autre promotion physique
qui l'aurait et il aurait ouvert le feu
avec un fusil de chasse avec les canons
sciés
donc voilà il ya les compressions
touchent à après pratiquement les
voisins qui ont entendu des
déflagrations ont privé nous les travées
sécuriser le scrutin
les amants qui changent notre être vite
et rapidement sur place derrière jolie
duché des merveilles on il a salué l'
l'efficacité et la rapidité et de ses
services et donc elle est prêtre est
évacuée il était amené à l'hôpital et
oui les fêtards état grave avec des
décorations que sa part la patrie et le
contexte actuel joe jonas terroriste
élevée quel est l'état d'esprit des
lyonnais ce soir
pas très angoissée on a pu enfin
contrairement à la wii mais titulaire en
sélection et la rue baraban je vous dis
pas qu'il est d'ailleurs on a parlé avec
quelques personnes s'étaient même pas
mais là-bas au viième arrondissement là
où la satisfaction
oui évidemment où les gens étaient très
proches angoissés et on a parlé avec des
passants avec moi sans nos syndiqués
oui c'est toujours ça commence quand
votre adversaire parce que ça change on
ne sait pas avec la pandémie maintenant
tout ça et c'est qu'il est choqué c'est
que j'étais en bénéficier j'en ai
entendu des détonations beaucoup d'entre
eux ils sont pareils sont pas satisfaits
car c'est tout de suite
il fallait y penser que c'était des feux
d'artifice et des pétards qui a été et
j'étais comme ça par les parisiens et
les noms ont été jetés des coûts de trop
beaucoup l'ont appris déjà à part à ses
côtés et quand internaliser il avait sur
lui l'été poids de sa famille dès que la
prévenue est dans notre pays et pour ce
qui est de ses passes et justement j'ai
pas mal chez lui et oui très les
français mènent déjà fait beaucoup mais
certains couche
donc oui c'est une espèce de climat de
guerre civile est un démon c'est le
monde a entendu et oui évidemment les
gens pour assurer qu'ils allaient y en a
qui soit merci beaucoup luis carballo
évidemment la piste terroriste n'est pas
encore confirmé en tout cas toutes les
pistes restent ouvertes
on va évidemment suivre cette affaire
dans nos prochaines éditions merci luis
carballo en direct de lyon et à la
veille de la toussaint alors que la
france étant d'état d'alert attentat le
premier ministre jean castex lui s'est
rendu avec sa ministre des armées à
rouen pour échanger avec les militaires
de l'opération sentinelle et la
communauté catholique
le chef du gouvernement s'est ensuite
rendu à saint-etienne du rouvray pour se
recueillir devant le monument en hommage
au père jacques hamel assassiné
sauvagement par deux terroristes
islamistes en 2016 écoutez le je me suis
rendu aujourd'hui à roanne est ici à
saint-etienne du rouvray avec madame la
ministre des armées pour m'assurer du
déploiement des forces sécurité et des
forces militaires supplémentaires que
nous avons décidé avec le président de
la république
de déployer autour non seulement des
lieux de culte mais également des
établissements scolaires à l'avant
veille de la rentrée
nous avons également eu un échange avec
le préfet avec le maire sur pour nous
assurer que l'ensemble des dispositions
étaient bien prises pour assurer la
sécurité de ces lieux et de ces
événements je dois vous dire que vous
devez compter sur l'entière
détermination du gouvernement de la
république pour permettre à tous et à
chacun de pratiquer son culte en toute
sécurité et en toute liberté
notre volonté est forte notre
détermination ne faiblira pas c'est
l'honneur de la france c'est l'honneur
de la république est alors que des
manifestations hostiles à la france se
poursuivent dans le monde arabo musulman
dans un entretien accordé à la
principale chaîne d'information du qatar
emmanuel macron dit comprendre que les
caricatures puisse choquer mais il
dénonce aussi la violence il affirme que
ses propos sur l'islam on était je cite
m manipuler je comprends qu'on puisse
être choqué par des caricatures mais je
n'accepterai jamais qu'on puisse
justifier la violence nos libertés nos
droits je considère que c'est notre
vocation de les protéger des
déclarations du président qui avait
entraîné l'appel au boycott de produits
français la semaine dernière c'était le
cas notamment de la turquie la turquie
qui risque d'avoir un effet boomerang
puisque les produits alimentaires des
cosmétiques les constructeurs
automobiles boycotter sont en fait des
secteurs qui
sont directement produit sur place en
france
l'appel au boycott du président recep
tayyip erdogan était intervenu justement
après la déclaration d' emmanuel macron
voyez ce qu'on dit notre spécialiste
suis tout de suite
il ya un effet boomerang potentiel
puisque ces produits sont effectivement
en grande partie fabriqués en turquie
on aurait pu citer peut-être le meilleur
exemple est celui des automobiles
renault
donc on sait qu'il ya une grande usine
présentant en turquie donc là aussi il
est clair que si ces automobiles ne sont
plus achetés par les turcs
même si elles ont vocation aussi être
exporté de toute façon et dans tous les
cas de figure ce sera une perte pour
l'économie tueur mais pour autant est-ce
que ce boycott va être durable est ce
que réellement les turcs ne vont pas
faire la part des choses
on pense notamment à cette population
turque au style alerte au gal qui
représente à peu près 50% de la
population donc peut-être que l à la
limite va faire le contraire de ce que
dire de garde justement pour le mettre
en difficulté les ivoiriens appelés aux
urnes aujourd'hui pour une élection
présidentielle sous tension depuis
l'annnonce de la troisième candidature
d'alassane ouattara le président sortant
qui vous voyait a voté un peu avant la
mi-journée l'opposition elle a appelé au
boycott et à la désobéissance civile à
la fermeture des bureaux de vote à 19h
l'opposition a parlé je cite d'un échec
du coup d'état institutionnel de la
présidence sortante
l'ancien rebelle guillaume soro lui a
appelé je cite à oeuvrer au départ
d'alassane ouattara un voyez les
précisions sur place à abidjan de notre
envoyé spécial samantha va me servir
aujourd'hui cet après midi plutôt
l'ancien président henri konan-bédié a
tenu une conférence de presse aux côtés
de pascal affi n'guessan est le leader
d'une frange du à ce pays le front
populaire ivoirien c'est le parti fondé
par laurent gbagbo
le grand absent de cette élection tous
les deux comme prévu n'ont pas voté et
ils ont réaffirmé qu'ils ne
reconnaissaient pas ce scrutin du 31
octobre
un scrutin sous haute sécurité marquée
par des heurts dans le sud du pays dans
les principaux fiefs de l'opposition
douze régions classées en rouge ou les
votes ont été empêchés dix régions
classées en orange ou là où c'est encore
assez tendu par exemple à gagnoa à
l'ouest le fief du f pays on a noté des
affrontements intercommunautaires
plusieurs maisons y ont été incendiés à
adzopé à l'ouest des affrontements entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre ont
été relevés et puis ici à abidjan nous
nous trouvons dès la fin de matinée des
échauffourées ont éclaté à un blockhaus
proche du quartier chic de cocody
là où le président sortant alassane
ouattara candidat pour un troisième
mandat eh bien à voter à 11h ce matin
et puis à yopougon kouté une commune
populaire d'abidjan on a noté la
présence d'hommes armés de machettes la
population s'est terrée chez elle et au
moment où on a quitté notre hôtel pour
rejoindre la commission électorale est
bien au niveau de la terrasse on pouvait
observer une épaisse colonne de fumée en
provenance justement de cette commune de
yopougon abidjan où aujourd'hui durant
toute cette journée la vie s'est
quasiment arrêté une ville morte
ce soir est la vie reprend peu à peu son
cours dans les quartiers populaires au
total 35 mille hommes étaient mobilisés
pour sécuriser plus de 22 mille bureaux
de vote qui ont fermé leurs portes
je propose d'écouter une réaction que
nous avons recueillis ce matin du
premier ministre ivoirien hamed bakayoko
mais la sécurité à 100% n'existe pas
quand vous avez dix mille bureaux de
vote
vous en mettez trois t3 agents pas durer
2 mois de ça fait trente mille et devant
des populations qui sont manipulés qui
arrive souvent à 53 cents nous avons
insisté auprès de nos hommes pour que la
gestion de ces foules la surface avec la
retenue
il avait insisté pour la gestion
démocratique des foules
parce qu'on a bien compris l'enjeu il
s'agissait de nous provoquer pour avoir
des bilans de morts ça et là pour tâcher
de ce scrutin mais ouais qui n'en n'est
rien on habille l'âge et de la sécurité
a tenu elle a été ferme mais n'a pas
débordé du tout et le scrutin je vous
assure j'ai vu les images j'ai vu le
compte-rendu sur l'ensemble du
territoire se passe normalement en
dehors de quelques points qui sont
malheureusement localiser et qui sont
les fiefs des opposants ça veut dire que
fondamentalement c'est susciter est les
prochaines heures vont être à surveiller
de près par crainte d'une flambée de
violences à l'annoncé des résultats ses
prochaines 24 heures on le rappelle
l'opposition qui a appelé à la
désobéissance civile pour contrer ce
troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
qu'elles jugent anticonstitutionnelle
on attend également d'en savoir un peu
plus en ce qui concerne le taux
d'abstention qui devrait être élevé dans
le pays puisque sur les 7,5 millions
d'électeurs inscrits 3 5 millions
disposer de leur carte d'électeur
justement on se rend dans quelques
instants
du côté de la commission électorale
indépendante pour un point presse
la crise sanitaire en france à présent
avec tout d'abord un point sur les
chiffres de l'épidémie regarder plus de
quarante neuf mille deux cent quinze
nouveaux cas de contamination détecter
ces dernières 24 heures ce qui porte à
plus d'un million trois cent trente
mille le nombre de cas positifs depuis
le début de l'épidémie
256 décès supplémentaires et près de
16000 300 hospitalisations
sur les sept derniers jours 1re
confinement appliquée aux petits
commerces non essentiels contesté par de
plus en plus de mères qui dénonce des
mesures déloyale face aux grandes
surfaces qui elles peuvent rester
ouverte
pour en parler nous sommes avec frédéric
jeanjean secrétaire général de l'union
des métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie 13 et eric straumann maire
de colmar bonsoir messieurs merci
beaucoup d'être là ce soir pour débattre
sur ce plateau d'ayrté france je
m'adresse tout d'abord avoue frédéric
jeanjean
pensez vous que les petits commerces
doivent rester ouverts écoutez ce que
nous pouvons dire c'est que nous avons
constaté que des maires lancé des appels
la situation est très complexe on sait
qui est l'épidémie
on sait qu'il ya un véritable danger on
sait qu'à côté de ça il va y avoir une
mise à mort de tout le tissu économique
et je parle des tpe des pme
donc il faut arriver à trouver des
solutions la difficulté c'est que nous
avons essayé nous à marseille nous avons
été les premiers à avoir été fermés dans
nos établissements cafés hôtels et
restaurants nous avions essayé discuter
avec le gouvernement
nous avons affaire à des gens qui sont
des technocrates sont froids et il faut
engager le rapport de forces qu'on
pouvoir au pouvoir discuter
à l'heure actuelle nous avons encore des
revendications nous avons des
revendications pour pouvoir sauver le
tissu économique
et si on veut sauver le tissu économique
j'entends ici et là qu'on nous dit c'est
pas ce que voulait sauver votre tiroir
caisse
je rappellerai simplement que nos
activités et la consommation dans son
ensemble parce que cela génère permet de
payer les retraites
la maladie et le chômage en france et
que c'est tout cet ensemble là qui va
être mise à mal
on veut briser la société on peut
envoyer déjà ouvert des livres ou pour
la restauration on peut les envoyer vers
amazon pour acheter on peut les envoyer
dans la grande distribution parce que
c'est plus facile à surveiller a
coordonné un contrôlé mais on ne peut
pas empêcher la vie on ne peut pas
empêcher la vie et je voudrais faire des
discours qui avait été fait par des
parlementaires à l'assemblée qui disait
il nous faut apprendre à vivre malgré le
virus ce qui est une richesse que vous
notez que frédéric jeanjean c'est
valable aussi pour les restaurants très
court pour les restaurants nous avons
mis en place un protocole sanitaire qui
est très claire dans aucune étude en
france on nous dit que c'est dans nos
établissements que le virus se transmet
on nous dit maintenant il faut réduire
les relations sociales ont longtemps
comme si l'on est transports en commun
les gens m'ont emmené les enfants à
l'école vont continuer à les travailler
enfin bon à un moment il faudrait un peu
de cohérence et eric straumann ai faites
vous partie de ces mères qui ont pris
des arrêtés justement pour permettre aux
petits commerces de leur commune de
rester ouvert justement pour ne pas les
laisser mourir
j'ai beaucoup hésité hier soir encore
des commerçants m'avait sollicité en
mettant en avant un certain nombre
d'arguments je sais que ce type d'aléas
d'arrêter et évidemment contestable
juridiquement je ne voulais pas non plus
donner de faux espoirs à mes commerçants
mais la réalité sur le terrain fait
qu'aujourd'hui je tourne aujourd'hui pas
expliquer la politique du gouvernement
j'ai un magasin de jouets en centre
ville de colmar qui est fermée qui a
stocké sa marchandise et qui attend de
pouvoir ouvrir éventuellement noël c'est
un magasin qui s'organisait pour
permettre la délivrance de la
marchandise dans toutes les conditions
sanitaires prescrites et bien ce magasin
est fermé et les gens vont aujourd'hui
htc s'est jouée dans l'est dans les
grandes surfaces et je n'ai aucun
argument objectif
d'ailleurs on va plutôt concentré tous
les acheteurs dans les grandes surfaces
alors que si on s'organise en centre
ville où les on peut faire faire la
queue aux gens à l'extérieur des
magasins avec le port du masque et
toutes les règles de distanciation et
notamment le gel je pense que le risque
est objectivement plus faible dans les
petits commerces de centre ville où il
ya cinq-six le client en simultané que
dans les grandes surfaces où on a bien
plus de monde et cet argument c'est un
argument factuel on va le défendre
devant le tribunal même si je sais que
c'est difficile alors les faits aussi de
ces arrêtés c'est que ça ça va quand
même pas mal remuer auprès des
administrations bien entendu le préfet
bad effet raymond arrêté comme suit des
trente et trente autres maires qui ont
pris même type d'arrêté devant le
tribunal administratif mais aussi celles
l'occasion d'un débat sur l'organisation
l'organisation de ce confinement bien
entendu je suis favorable mesures les
plus strictes lorrains étaient très
touchés lors de la première période par
le co 10 19 on a eu des centaines de
bord dans notre département
aujourd'hui la situation s'est améliorée
alors je ne sais pas si c'est lié à une
forme d'immunité collective mais mr je
me suis convaincu qu'on peut permettre
l'ouverture des petits commerces sans
créer un risque particulier de
développement dulko vide en respectant
bien entendu un certain nombre de règles
et en évitant la concentration dans les
grandes surfaces
lorsque vous prenez un chariot vous
prenez déjà un risque lorsque vous avez
lorsque vous rentrez dans le commerce
etc on revêt des marchandises le risque
infiniment plus faibles j'espère que le
gouvernement va prendre conscience de
cette situation
je sais que bruno le maire et travaille
le sujet et combattre houben une
solution au moins pour ce type de
commerce au courant du début de la
semaine prochaine
c'est si je ne trompe que ministre de
l'économie avait plaidé justement pour
sauver ces petits commerces pour qu'il
reste ouvert
ils ont moins de trésorerie que les
grands groupes finalement
frédéric jeanjean est ce que c'est pas
eux qu'on aurait dû sauver avant de
laisser ouvert les grandes surfaces par
exemple pour ces raisons de trésorerie
et de faillite
écoutez les grandes surfaces joue sur le
fait qu' il faut travailler sur
l'alimentation de la population
moi j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
maires discuter avec eux ici dans le
département des bouches du rhône
le comité départemental du tourisme
avait mis en jeu pour un montant de 300
mille euros des passes à gagner pour
manger au restaurant en emporter en
livrer ou sur place à l'époque où nous
étions ouverts il ya tout un tas
d'initiatives a lancé pour soutenir le
commerce de proximité
parce que vous savez nous dans nos
activités
1 nous ne défiscalisant bas dont nous
restons sur place
2 c'est une pérennité et vous avez des
familles entières qui vivent par nos
activités parce que vous avez des
salariés vous avez des chefs
d'entreprise vous avez et c'est tout un
tissu qu'on est en train de mettre à mal
alors on voudrait une brise et cette
société on dans la standardiser qu'avec
des normes c'est la facilité
technocratiquement ça passe bien sur le
papier
dans les faits ça va poser énormément de
soucis je vais vous dire les choses
comme elles sont à l'heure actuelle je
tire la sonnette d'alarmé parce que je
pense que d'ici quelques semaines nous
allons nous retrouver avec des émeutes
de la faim en france et je vais vous
donner un exemple très simple il ya
quantité des magasins autour de mon
établissement où les vendeurs et
vendeuses travaillons un fixe et ensuite
une grosse part variable
là ce mois ci leurs commerces étaient
ouverts ils vont pouvoir toucher leur
salaire à la fin du mois de novembre
la part variable aura disparu et nous
allons nous trouver avec les chefs
d'entreprises en tpe pme qui eux n'ont
pas le chômage partiel
ils n'ont pas de couverture on leur a
proposé 1500 euros transformable en dix
mille euros
il faut voir la paperasse quêtes à
remplir il faut voir les délais nous ça
fait six semaines qu'on nous a promis
tout un tas dead à marseille
quand monsieur
vers ans et monsieur galilée était venu
monsieur castex a dit il ya une semaine
de ça lundi matin ce sera fait mardi au
plus tard
en attendant toujours les décrets donc
vous savez c'est au quotidien après il
faut faire bouillir la marmite et quand
je dis faire bouillir la marmite il faut
faire ses courses il faut pouvoir
avancer et là je pense qu'à la fin du
mois de novembre et à l'approché des
fêtes de fin d'année on va arriver sur
quelque chose de très tendue vous avez
tous les gens qui ont des petits boulots
au tour tous les gens qui étaient s'en
sortir qui ne peuvent plus sortir du
fait du confinement
vous avez tous ces paramètres là qui
vont générer derrière une crise sociale
qui sera aussi une crise économique et
il y aura beaucoup plus de morts des
conséquences de cette politique là que
du conte vite je pense eric straumann
c'est votre c'est ce que vous entendez
parmi les les personnes qui veulent
garder leurs commerces ouverts dans
votre commune la faillite est alors je
suis dans une
je suis pas dans une ville de la taille
de mars est évidemment c'est une petite
file et vous savez que dans l'est dans
les villes moyennes
on a des difficultés pour maintenir on
vit les commerces de centre-ville alors
colmar a toujours bénéficié d'une
situation plutôt favorable en raison de
la fréquentation touristique
mais là on risque de franchir un seuil
qui va tout simplement apparaître de
nombreux commerces du centre-ville
assécher l'offre commerciale de
centre-ville était et on aura des
rideaux qui sont tirées personne n'a
intérêt à ce que nous centre ville
disparaissent au profit du commerce eu
deux dents lieu c'est un modèle aussi à
sauver jeu faut je pense que le
gouvernement doit en avoir conscience
parce que dans nos villes moyennes
beaucoup de commerces ont notamment
dépendant des fêtes de fin d'année les
bijouteries les vagues à des magasins
textile et la marge réalisée en fin
d'année autour des périodes de noël
et si ces magasins sont fermés durant
cette période
malheureusement pas de marge et c'est
tout simplement la disparition de ces
commerces ce qui nous guette le
gouvernement qui voulait privilégier
aussi l'industrie de proximité c'est le
cas pour ces petits commerces ce serait
la mort aussi de de ce principe qu'on
avait défendu pendant le premier
confinement elle est cependant c'est
surtout la wii c'est surtout en fait
l'alimentation de proximité ça par
contre ça a très bien fonctionné nous
avons des maraîchers sur colmar on a des
filières courtes
fonctionne très très bien et d'ailleurs
on sent la population a décidé de
retourner vers les commerces locaux
on a d'un marché qui fonctionne très
bien depuis la fin du déconfinement et
d'ailleurs je remercie gouvernement qui
a décidé de maintenir ses marchés on
s'en souvient lorsque 2 lors de la
première période de confinement les
marchés étaient fermés c'est qui était
une mauvaise chose puisque là encore ça
profitait aux grandes surfaces donc le
gouvernement à avancer sur ce sujet
parce que je pense qu'on ne prend pas
plus de risques en alors sur un marché
qu'on alors dans un supermarché allons
faire un pas encore un peu plus loin
pour que cette rupture d'égalité entre
les grandes surfaces et des petits
commerçants ben disparaissent c'est pour
permettre l'achat mais toujours dans les
règles de confinement dans les règles
distanciation sociale dans les règles
sanitaires sans prendre aucun risque
supplémentaire permettons à ces
commerces non alimentaires de travailler
en cette période de noël
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
répondu ce soir à nos questions en
direct sur arte france et c'est la fin
de ce journal merci de votre fidélité
on se retrouve dans 30 minutes rester
avec nous
[Musique]
les ouvrages n'ont jamais souhaité vivre
dans la crise mais il se trouve que déjà
ou déraison d'ambition politique
tant que nous organiser nous les
baigneurs divisé le pays en deux de
pouvoir lui même avec ses policiers avec
ces gens là